joining us right now is the man who
planted the flag dotted the oh if you
will
Baker Mayfield here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Baker I'm doing fine so
let's start with the flag okay I'm sure
you figured that was coming so let's uh
let's let's start with the flag why did
you do it at the time Oh obviously very
excited it was a big win for us we knew
it was you know obviously had last year
on our minds first of all but then you
know just the implications on the rest
of our season and you know what it
stands for you know considering playoffs
and down the road it's just it was a big
win so it was an emotional one for me
and I was just you know so I've ridden
with the guys and having fun well I mean
just so you know this okay I know some
diehard Oklahoma fans who flat-out loved
it I mean they absolutely loved it that
it was showing some brass and and not
brass that was unearned earned brass and
I'm wondering if that was part of what
you were going through at that moment
not just about the loss to Ohio State
but about you know your coach having
departed and this program needing a win
like that yeah I think it was it was
important for this program on many
different reasons but at the same time
it was like you said it was well earned
and we worked very hard during the week
I think we had a great great practice
week you know in preparation we were
very focused and so it was kind of like
you know that that feeling of it's all
been worth it and that a whole week
everything and you gone through so it
was very enjoyable
so why apologize for it Baker there's
you know caught a lot of flack for it
I wouldn't necessarily if I went back in
time I wouldn't necessarily go back and
you know do it any differently just I
mean it was it was what it was it
happened I mean it was an emotional and
I think we deserved it we deserve to
celebrate and every bit of it but
there's a lot of sensitive people in
this world in this day and age so you
know I'm going to offend a lot of people
it's
you know the nature of being additional
men so gotta you know try and stay a
little bit level-headed and enjoy the
wind but at the same time not take too
many people off so I think I actually
caught more flak from from Oklahoma fans
after I apologized then people in Ohio
[Laughter]
take a back baker they don't want you to
take it back there are no backsies when
you plant a flag in the middle of the
horse I mean I mean it wouldn't it
wasn't meant to be disrespectful
directly towards Ohio State so no I
wouldn't take it back but it was it was
meant to be you know just just for our
team and a statement for us so are you
that type of player if you ever play
chess that you keep your finger on the
piece after you make the move and it's
not official until you take the finger
off the piece is that oh absolutely
that's a complete complete rule and you
got to stare them down to make sure
mm-hmm see the reaction so was your
fingers so as your fingers still on the
flag is what I'm saying Baker right now
is you and I are talking a few days
later your fingers still on the flag
it's you haven't removed it just yet oh
it's on the flag and you know I still
think we have a couple moves to make
Baker Mayfield joining me here on the
Rich Eisen show what did you see however
against that Ohio State defense that you
were able to exploit a defense that you
know has a stout front seven to the
point where Greg Schiano the current
defensive coordinator said is the best
defensive line he's ever coached
which ruffled some feathers back at the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers locker I can tell
you that yeah I don't think our boy
Gerald McCoy took that one too hot but
hey you know a great defense don't get
me wrong but we have a great offense and
so I have to discredit them but I think
we're just a very good team and we're
confident we believe in ourselves right
now so we have every right to do so I
think we've had a lot of guys experience
and a lot of guys that have been through
a lot in this program played a lot of
ball but we just we believed in doing
our job and coach Riley and the often
staff they put in a great game plan for
us and we just went out there and did
what they ate kosher stuff all week to
do how did you hear about Bob Stoops
leaving Baker
from some friends back home they were
gonna tell us that day a little bit
later in the day I had a team meeting
called and they were gonna announce it
but it just make to the media a little
bit earlier than that and so I had
friends from back home calling me and
asking me what was going on quite
frankly I didn't know what the truth was
until I had gotten up here to the
football facilities and so how did you
take the news then it was shocking you
know I definitely thought I'd finish out
my career here with Coach Stoops you
know he's growing up as a know you fan
he was all I ever knew with Oklahoma
football but so it was shocking but at
the same time he talking to him and
hearing his explanation and just felt
like at the right time and he had he had
the team and he had the same staff would
be able to take over and not let the
program slip and he's exactly right
coach Riley's the best coach in the
country and and I think that he left it
in in great hands and there's no doubt
about it is there any difference with
coach Riley but you can point to no
disrespect to coach Stoops but obviously
coach Raleigh's his own man and a
different man and a different maybe
culture different approach I'm wondering
if there is any I mean I wouldn't say
there's some huge difference but it's
definitely you know people feel that the
energy that he brings to the program and
that fire in the passion you know and I
think that's why people it's compared
him to when they first hired coach
Stoops here and he had a lot of juice
and a lot of energy ready to go out
there and compete and so I think it's
similar in that way mm-hmm
Baker Mayfield joining me here for a few
more minutes here on the Rich Eisen show
a lot of folks think that you might be
seeing Oklahoma State twice this year
what do you think I don't know you got a
one game at a time mentality and I know
whenever I ask a football question about
something down the road so I'm
front-loading to not get the cliche but
it looks like Oklahoma State and you
guys might play one another twice what
do you think Baker whoever we played
twice they can get it
it doesn't matter right now it's just
about taking like you like you said when
we get a time but it won't matter
we're going to treat everybody the same
and we'll see you it is and I have the
confidence in our team as we'll get to
that point so obviously he's a lot of
ball to play list you know we had to
take care of it at that point but it
won't matter we're playing then
do you like the fact that there's a
championship game in this toughest I
love it I think it'll be another
showcase for us to show what we're about
on a national you know stage or for the
committee down the road you know like I
said we got to take care of business
before that but I think it hurt our
chances a couple years ago I think with
TCU and Baylor that first year the
playoffs it hurt them
not being able to have a championship
game to maybe get a spot in the playoff
but it'll be good for us now who is your
quarterback growing up who was the guy
that you admired and you may be modeled
your game after Baker Mayfield Brett
Favre you did not stutter there I
noticed no not at all why what do you
like about him he just it just brings a
lot of energy to the game he's a winner
and he's a competitor you know I just
you enjoy watching him he has fun with
it he's always the first guy down there
to celebrate and he's always making a
joke and keeping it light but at the
same time he flips the switch on and
turned it on have you spoken to him
chatted with him at all I have not my
brothers met him so he kind of holds
that over my head hmm
what do you mean your brothers met him
yeah well my brother went to high school
with Mike McCarthy's daughter so they've
been friends and he went up to a couple
Green Bay games a few years ago and
watched him play but so he met him when
he was up in in Green Bay but you know
I'll hopefully get to meet him someday
is this something you'd like me to make
happen Baker Mayfield I can make this
Howard I would enjoy that okay so here's
the scoop are you and Brett Farve are
gonna get on the phone I'm gonna I'm a
what we're gonna do is get your number
either when you hang up or from from the
S ID there and you and Brett Farve it'd
be my honor to help you do two guys up
you could chat it out and and then you
just got to let me know a little bit of
what you guys talk about that's all just
you know I don't believe that's a
violation is that a violation do you
think conversation no yeah you're just
giving him a phone number do you think
Brett Favre would have planted that flag
Baker Mayfield in the middle of the
horseshoe I don't know whatever you
might have but I think you do enjoy well
you're gonna get a chance to ask him
to make that happen and last one for you
were you planting that flag for the big
12 as well there's four teams in the big
12 in the top 20 and I know just up
there now just for Oklahoma okay there
is an I in Mayfield man I love it
Baker I really love the way you play
moot Mariucci was on the show yesterday
he said that you've got the skillset of
an NFL quarterback a thousand percent so
I do believe I will be seeing you at the
next level shortly but in the meantime
I'll enjoy watching you what you're
doing appreciate that you got it
Baker Mayfield who's gonna be chat with
Brett Favre I'm gonna make that happen
I'm a man of my word
I spent the commercial break texting
number four himself saying just ready
would you like me to give the exchange I
would just hey Brett just had Baker
Mayfield on the show and says you were
his guy slash Idol growing up I asked if
you've ever met and he said no I asked
if he wanted to connect and he
emphatically said yes would you be up
for connecting with him let me know best
Indiana are and then it will hold up my
phone to the camera if you want to get
that Pritchett get in there I will say
can you can you see what it says
of course he responded I like the way he
plays and Baker Mayfield we're gonna
make this happen number four I love it
he likes the way plays one how would he
liked about the flag planting you love
the fact that he's kind of still like a
yes and remove the piece yet the move
still takes place a lot of sensitive
people out there you make that chess
move it doesn't count it's like cakes a
finger off and matter what you say you
make that move and you're like looking
around what does it mean what does it
mean it says there's a lot of sensitive
people in the world although he said he
got more grief from Oklahoma fans for
taking it back that's what I'm saying
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy